on revient donc sur ce procès de 5
activistes écologistes accusés d'avoir
dégradé à la peinture il y a quelques
mois le mur d'enceinte de la préfecture
d'Indre-et-Loire arrivée libre au
tribunal de Tours il risque 50 prisons
mais pour ces militants âgés de 19 à 28
ans l'audience était une nouvelle
occasion de dénoncer l'inaction
climatique sur place Lucas Chopin
c'est un procès éminemment politique qui
se joue au tribunal de tour au moment où
je vous parle un procès qui oppose la
métropole de Tours la préfecture et le
Conseil départemental d'Indre-et-Loire à
5 jeunes militants des militants du
groupe écologiste dernière rénovation
pour rappel les cinq prévenus
comparaissent aujourd'hui pour avoir
peint orange une partie de la façade de
la préfecture et du département le 22
mars dernier à Tours un acte qui avait
pour but de dénoncer l'inaction
gouvernementale face aux dérèglement
climatiques un acte symbolique pour ses
auteurs qui attendent désormais une
réponse tout aussi symbolique de la part
de la justice en tant que vraiment
symbole de l'application de la
législature française ils ont aussi un
devoir de d'entrer dans l'histoire et
de changer le cours de l'histoire pour
que nous on ne soit pas condamnés plus
tard et moi je veux les mettre face à
leur responsabilité moi j'ai pris les
miennes en faisant cette section et à
eux de prendre les leurs pour que
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas l'histoire de
l'humanité ne s'arrête pas en ouverture
de l'audience les prévenus ont lu des
déclarations tour à Tours pour justifier
leurs actes vous êtes notre dernier
recours madame la Présidente
précise-t-il nous réclamons votre aide
pour la préservation de la vie sur terre
chaque mot et chaque symbole sont pesés
de prévenus arbore les t-shirts qu'ils
portaient le 22 mars l'une présente même
des chaussures tachées de peinture
orange vous n'êtes pas en position de
neutralité avec ses vêtements Hassana
présidente mais cet après-midi la
neutralité est vraisemblablement rester
sur les parvis du tribunal ou nombre de
militants écologistes et membres du
convoi de l'eau se sont retrouvés un
symbole fort pour l'un des co-prévenu ça
fait extrêmement au cœur de voir que
comme nous d'autres organisations mais
aussi des élus et des associations des
individus s'unissent pour éviter le pire
mais pas seulement aussi pour lutter
pour de meilleurs lendemain des
meilleurs lendemain qui sont possibles
et mais qui manque seulement la volonté
politique pour voir le jour et c'est
aussi d'abord et avant tout pourquoi
nous sommes là aujourd'hui et on espère
qu'on pourra continuer davantage à
l'avenir à l'avenir cette convergence
des luttes qui est essentielle le
procureur a requis 100 jours amende à
l'encontre des cinq prévenues d'ici
quelques minutes les avocats des
militants devraient plaider l'état de
nécessité pour tenter de faire relaxer
leurs clients une issue peu probable au
vu de la reconnaissance des faits et des
remarques de la présidente durant
l'audience